the EAS reaction can also be used to
introduce a sulphonic acid group onto an
aromatic ring in this lesson we're going
to look at two sets of conditions that
can cause this reaction to occur we will
first look at the sulphonation of
benzene with sulfuric acid to produce
our sulphonic acid this will shed light
on the subtleties of our second
mechanism where we use sulfur trioxide
to produce the electrophile needed for
this reaction two molecules of sulfuric
acid must react this equilibrium is
going on to a small extent in a solution
of sulfuric acid let's add on our lone
pairs to keep track of them a little bit
better and then we can show the O H
group of one molecule of sulfuric acid
becoming pronated by the acidic proton
on a second molecule of sulfuric acid
this gives the conjugate base of
sulfuric acid and this oxonium keeping
track of our charges notice that our
first molecule gave up a proton and
gained an extra lone pair this gives it
the formal negative charge on oxygen the
second molecule of sulfuric acid shared
a lone pair to become protonated and
that's how we get the oxonium ion with a
positive charge now we're going to show
water act as a leaving group to generate
our electrophile but notice two atoms
away we have another oxygen atom so we
can facilitate the departure of the
leaving group by using its lone pair
from this process we get water and a
protonated form of sulfur trioxide which
is a great electrophile benzene can now
attack with its double bond to give an
intermediate carbo cation the resonance
stabilized conjugate base of sulfuric
acid is not a good nucleophile so we can
show water deprotonating this molecule
to form our sulphonic acid the reaction
we just shown is rather slow this is
because we're depending on the
calibration of a strong acid in solution
to form small amounts of protonated
sulfur trioxide which can then push the
reaction forward when it reacts with
benzene but that overall equilibration
is not very favorable so this reaction
does take some time we can carry out
this reaction more efficiently using
sulfur trioxide in sulfuric acid this
reagent is called fuming sulfuric acid
and when you open the bottle it does
indeed smoke do this in a fume hood it's
very corrosive this mechanism can be
drawn a couple ways notice above we
generated a protonated form of sulfur
trioxide now the protonation of so3 may
be the first step in this reaction under
certain conditions however benzene can
also attack sulfur trioxide directly and
we'll show that mechanism here benzene
attacks so3 pushing the electrons up
onto oxygen restoring aromaticity in
this molecule is a strong driving force
so some people opt to show a spontaneous
deprotonation here but we also have
appropriate bases in solution to do this
deprotonation if we use sulfur trioxide
to do the deprotonation we can create
that great electrophile that we
generated in the above mechanism so
we'll show another molecule of sulfur
trioxide deprotonating benzene and a
final protonation of this anion will
give our sulphonic acid which was drawn
above let's take a look at the
properties of the sulphonic acid
derivative that we've just made this is
an electron withdrawing group we can
show how electron density is pulled out
of the Ring using one of the sulfur
oxygen double bonds this resonance form
has positive character at the ortho
position of the aromatic ring we can
continue to push electrons around the
ring and show that there's positive
character at the para and the other
ortho position of this aromatic ring
thus the sulphonic acid group is a
deactivating group
it pulls the electrons out of the ring
that benzene needs to undergo further
electrophilic aromatic substitution
reactions the electrons within the ring
are less available to attack
electrophiles on this compound the meta
carbons are the most electron rich so
when we treat benzene sulfonic acid with
a powerful enough electrophile remember
the electrophile needs to be pretty
powerful now that the ring is
deactivated the new group will be
introduced at the meta position in this
lesson we looked at two methods for the
sulphonation of benzene we then looked
at the properties of the derivative that
we made benzene sulphonic acid we saw
that the introduction of this group
makes benzene less reactive to further
EA s reactions however when it does
react the groups will be added at the
meta position